what is a loose outline versus maybe a
more structured outline
well for me when i do an outline i uh it
gets much easier after you've written a
few books because i think you sort of
find an internal rhythm
so for me my books tend to fall around
70 to 90 000 words that's kind of the
average range and i
tend to have about uh you know 30 to 40
chapters like
and my chapters tend to be 1500 to 2000
words each you know so having gone
through it and
now knowing that i can sort of lay out
you know what it's going to be so
you know i tend to i tend to almost like
note carding for a screenplay i usually
take an excel document and i just
put 40 you know rows and i just sort of
write each chapter what i think will
happen
you know just a couple sentences i don't
go too crazy
but i do know other people that create
you know 30 40 page outlines where
they're really
going into the nitty-gritty and the
detail of it so again it just depends
what works for you
so basically when you start a new novel
you will go to that excel document and
you'll do 40 rows and just loosely put
out
maybe not even what the title is called
but just yeah the title is
usually i mean i usually start with the
title but sometimes i change it you know
i mean
sometimes it's just a working sometimes
i know it's just a working title other
times you know that just
like come up with a better idea you know
sure so then just one or two sentences
about what's going to happen
yeah and it's not always complete i mean
i find if i know the ending it's usually
for the best but sometimes i don't and
sometimes
i just reach a point where i'm like you
know what i'll just have to figure it
out when i get there you know
and i'll start but usually i try to know
you know what the ending is going to be
so have you ever gotten stuck where you
really couldn't sort of write your way
out of it
no but i sometimes it's more work than
it would have been you know
there's a so i have a science fiction
series uh called talon
and the fourth book in that i know i did
have an outline it was a loose outline
but i
there were a couple things i think i
should have nailed down a little bit so
i got about three quarters i was like
you know what i need to go back and
change some stuff so i kind of put that
aside and worked on something else for a
little while and then i'll come back to
it
and kind of not start over but just
you know backtrack a little bit change
some things let the effects ripple out
and then
you know go forward and finish it but in
kane it's usually been pretty
straightforward i think i tend to have a
clear
idea of what the ending's going to be
because it's
you know with science fiction it's sort
of tough because anything can happen you
know it's very
a very big genre whereas with spy
thrillers you know it's a little more
contained and
the outcomes need to be a little more
imaginable you know like sort of by
definition
was it your intention to make it a
series oh yeah oh from the very
beginning
yeah i mean i didn't know if i could
really follow through with it
but i mean i always loved those kinds of
series characters
i mean i i was a huge comic book fan
growing up i liked that kind of
storytelling
so certainly in my head i always thought
you know as i was writing it i had ideas
for what the next book would be
and i you know i tried to kind of just
keep those compartmentalized because
it's like well
we'll see let's see if you get through
this one you know but yeah i intended it
to be a series
do you have writing rules that you live
by hmm what do you mean can you
elaborate more you know i mean some
people say you know never be boring i
don't know
though these are these cliche you know
writing is rewriting there's so many
different ones but
ones that you just well i i
i don't know if they're rules i would
say that either maybe they're more
well the rule the only rule is
once once i start a project i write
every day
i mean it's a job to me you know so like
you know in between books i might not
but once i have started a book it's like
okay i'm now writing 2000 words a day on
this book
usually i take off weekends you know
monday through friday i just i try to be
professional about it
so i'd say i guess that's a rule but in
terms of
guidelines i try to follow i
i read a lot of books you know before i
started one of the things that inspired
me to start was i would read books and
i think if you read enough and write
enough you come to a point where you
start to realize that
you're reading something like i could do
better than this or i could do it
at this you know i could at least do
something as good as this maybe i could
do something better than this
and i noticed a lot of books i felt like
the um
locations didn't really come alive for
me you know i would read in there just
say oh we're in syria and
it never really felt like it or the
author didn't really dive into it in
more detail
and that was something i really i wanted
to do differently because again going
back to ian fleming one of the things i
appreciate about his books are he was a
journalist and he had an eye for detail
and when you read
one of his books you really get the
sense that he went to that place you
know and you feel like you've gone there
and it's even stranger with him because
he was writing in the 1950s so you
almost feel like you've gone back in
time you know to this other place
because
that place he's writing about you know
doesn't exist anymore
so you know i always try to make sure
that i
am uh bringing the location to life you
know for the reader like
without going overboard i don't want to
like pound them over the head with
details but i just want them to feel
like they were there i also uh
i think from the cinematic side a thing
that i would notice is i would feel like
the action
in books sometimes would kind of fall
flat for me you know like the example i
always give is uh
you'd read a thriller and at the end the
guy's chasing the bad guy up to a roof
and he gets the roof and he shoots them
and the guy falls off the roof and
that's the end you know and i was like
that's too easy you know
like so you know to me like if that's
going to be your climax like
the guy should run up to the roof and
then the other guy jumps over to the
next building and then the hero jumps
but he falls through the skylight now
he's running underneath the bad guy you
know i always try
so i call that uh i always try to
escalate the action you know
i want i want the action to like sort of
build and build and
so like you know a yes but or does the
hero succeed
yes but or does he fail yes and you know
like kind of keep it going
to one or two levels you know beyond
what would be obvious when you start the
scene
so the i don't think are rules per se
but those are things i always try to do
that's important to me that that's kind
of what i like to see in a book so
that's what i try to put into mine
are your books heavy on dialogue or it's
mostly action
i don't know honestly i'd say
a little both i mean i'd say it's pretty
even i mean it's a
it's a thriller so i think you're going
to have more action than in a drama
um but i certainly don't intentionally
cut the dialogue but i do try to write i
think my style is naturally a little
more terse you know more
more on the sort of hemingway or
chandler side than the fitzgerald side
you know i think that's just my natural
rhythm and do you speak out the
characters
did you no no i don't i do know authors
who do that
um and i also know authors who dictate
uh instead of actually typing they you
know they speak
they speak it i've tried to do that but
it's very alien to me i just feel
the connection of with my fingers to the
keyboard just feels much more natural
um but now i don't uh i don't speak the
dialogue
yeah i can't imagine doing that but i
noticed it works for some people when i
directed uh
the independent movie that i did the the
which i also wrote
uh one of the actresses said she would
drive her crazy she said
i would be mouthing the words next to
the camera which i wasn't consciously
aware of doing
i certainly wasn't trying to do that but
she's like stop it you know i was like
what
she's like i see your mouth moving like
so
i think maybe maybe maybe as i'm writing
i am and i just don't realize it i don't
know
that should have been in the player
that's really funny by the way what was
that film about just quickly well
it's a very very strange uh it is a it
is a
comedy about bad catholic school girls
ah
okay i'm sure there's an audience
but it's not it's not what you would
think okay i should have i would
probably make much more money if i
made it exactly what you think it would
be but it's much more of a
it's kind of a cross between john waters
and john hughes you know
okay did you go to catholic school i
didn't but my girlfriend in high school
did
so i sort of had an exterior insanity
you